well the thing is first of all the moral
argument to me is is strong enough
you're a human being and you see a bunch
of people suffering and you have the
resources to help that's a simple enough
answer to me is help and if you can
think of a reason why not to then you
tell me but I think that more reason is
plenty and then once you have that
you've established that then you think
of the selfish reason why you would want
to help think of you know how terrorism
knocked on our door in New York and at
nine eleven and and you realize that
what happens on the other side of the
world actually has an impact on what
happens here and all the unrest that
happens around the world a lot of it a
major cause is a battle for scarce
resources poverty despair hunger
unemployment it feeds a lot of the rage
and the strife and a lot of the
political unrest that happens in these
other places around the world and we
know now that that political unrest has
its way of finding of finding us where
we live in the Western world and so if
you don't believe in the more logic
behind philanthropy and behind trying to
do something about poverty then at least
believe in the security argument and the
selfish motives we might have to care
about the rest of the world
you